Y
BEEN MEETING IN THE TRUMP
CLFI
S  BHA
STE
WITNESSES IN RECEND IS
R E
TNT TO KRISTINMES
WHE SEARCH WARRANT FOR
MAR-A-LAGO WAS APPROVED.
TELL US MORE.
>> Reporter: WE KNOW THE GAS BET
HOUSE IN ME HED
FROM A NUMR  WITNESSES.CTED TARO
ANOTS IN THE STIGAT CD
PRAND AFR
MOREITNESS.
NO NOT CLEAR IS WHY TLY THEY HA
AN.
I TAO A NUMBER OF SOURCECLOS TRW
WERE ALSO RE WHY THIS D JURY WAH
ONE THING TO NOTE,H
COUNL  OPERATE A
CHARGES IN ANYION. THIS IS COMPS
THE -- THE COURT THAT SIGNED OFF
ON TARNT
THE OTHER THINABE UT
THAT'SESTINGANSISTANT U.S. ATTO
MIAM W PRESENT
THAT SEARCRRS EXUT
AT MAR-A-LAGO.THERE HAVE BEEN T
E SINCECIAL COUNSEL
TOOK OVER BECAUSE IT DEALTH
TAKING DOCUMENTSROHOE  TRUMP'S .
P.
BUT IT'STI WHY
Y THEY HAVE CONVENED THE
SECOND GRAND JURY, WHY THEY ARE
>> KRISTIN HOLMES WITH THENG NE.
SO MUCH.ING IN SENIOR LEGAL
DOCUMENTSE THE O INOW WE'VE KNO
BUT NOW E HEARINMORE FROM
OUREPORTERS THE
GRAND JURY IN FLORIDA.
SEE TWO BROAD
ONE IS THIUL
IERE ARE
WITNESSEWHT OR WON'T
FL IS TAKE A FEDERAL GRAND
JURY DOWN THERE AND TAKEHETRANS
IN JURY IN D.C.
OTHER POSSIL
PROSECUTORS COULD BEXAMINING IB
CASE DOWTHERN
RIIDE YOU HAVE
TO CN ONE SOMECRIMINONCCURRED.
YOU HAEEY BU
GET IT
IF YOUHA THE WRONG
TH
THROUT.
>>D E SOME SORT OF CRIMINAL CHAT
HAVING TO ITH HOLDING THE
ANE OBCE
WOULD E IN TWO
DIERT JURISDICTIONS N IM D
THINK THATSEOULD D
THAT WLDES IN O LS GOING ON AME.
DECIDE ARE WARGIING THIS
R ORIDA?
OF THE VINTHE JURYOOL IS BETTER
OBCKIVACURRED. CHARGING IN. YOU.
UL IT HA
INDICTMENT IN FLORIDA IT HAS
WE KNOERICE DEME OFFICIALSALD T.
YESTERDAY.
PRS WHEN THEY HAGE
THESE MEETINGS?
CO THEM
NOT TOINCT
TIVE T USUALLY.E SEFUL,
PRESENTATIONVINCE NOT